the Supreme Court is saving its most
significant rulings for the final day of
its term today one case considers a
trump administration's plan to add a
citizenship question to the 2020 census
the justices are also looking at how
congressional districts are drawn Jan
Crawford is at the Supreme Court Jan I
think it's going to be a busy day for
you but let's start with that census
case why is it causing some controversy
well I mean it would be the first time
that the formal census which as you know
has taken every 10 years would ask
people if they're citizens since 1950
the census hasn't done that since since
back then and the administration says
that it needs that accurate citizenship
information you know just to properly
enforce the Voting Rights Act but
opponents are saying come on this is
just going to deter non-citizens from
even responding to the census at all
which means they're not going to be
properly counted and why is that
important that census data is used for a
whole bunch of important things like for
example how many seats and the House of
Representatives each state gets and also
those billions of dollars in federal
funding for things like schools and
roads how is that divvied up so very
important issues at stake in that sense
this case
yeah you've touched on it Jan but can
you explain why the redistricting cases
are so important all right this sounds
like a very complicated case and it is
but the bottom line is it's going to
determine how states draw up their
legislative districts the court has long
held that you can't discriminate based
on race when you're drawing up
legislative districts you can't dilute
minority votes for example but what
about efforts by the political party to
kind of hold on to that power and draw
up the district's just for that purpose
can that ever be too extreme so the
Justice today are gonna look at those
partisan efforts that redistricting and
whether or not that's okay or when it's
not okay all right Jan thank you very
much